[Music]
Atticus atlas one of the world's largest
moths Fillion giganteum ghost insects
that look like leaves de nasties
Hercules
one of the biggest beetles on earth they
all make up just a small part of our DN
Casa Kiev itches insect collection the
young breeder has found millions of
Internet fans with his videos of bugs
and spiders
he says handling them is anything but a
key different human take control
I've always had insects at home I'd
catch them outside and then breed them
like a thief if it's part of me it's
normal in Dayton and tighter and this is
a trusted - the 20 year old has more
than half a million friends on Facebook
alone
many of his clips have gone viral
they're now making him money Artyom can
earn between 200 and 400 euros per clip
for the rights the wackier the content
the more likely it is to attract
interest with agencies his biggest hits
are his selfie videos this 1500 mile
wide normally it doesn't feel creepy the
big ghost insects are the exception
since they have claws and like to latch
on near your eyes that's unpleasant what
was also unpleasant was the world's
biggest snail I had it on my face and it
was too slimy yeah do you want y'all
simply - yeah
our turn shoots most of his videos in
the suburban neighborhood near cars were
his parents basement has kept at 24
degrees Celsius the preferred
temperature of insects like the Goliath
beetle it can grow to 11 centimeters and
usually lives in Africa
another highlight are his Australian
giant cockroaches a pair of them costs
250 euros avianna owns 50 different
insect and spider species most are
mantises skip Arden video there are
species like this one that are perfectly
adapted to dead leaves there are others
that also imitate living leaves or
flowers there's a huge variety of types
that's what's so fascinating about
mantises got it emit in advance insects
are easy to care for mantises are
carnivores that eat live locusts and
spiders by contrast stick insects from
Madagascar get fresh blackberry leaves
every three days
insects make up the largest group of
fauna there are still many undiscovered
species living in rainforests three to
four times a year our town goes to
southeastern Asia to get new species
although none that are endangered
nonetheless animal rights activists have
complained that he is misusing the
insects as commodities and pets if you
loiter immensely yes many people
personify insects too much insects have
no consciousness all they sense things
like temperature humidity and the
nutrients in the creatures they eat if
you give them that everything is fine
Adrien social media success extends
beyond insect fanatics recently luxury
Italian fashion designer Gucci invited
him to Florence to blog at an exclusive
fashion show these thorny devil stick
insects are particularly popular among
his fans because they're both rare and
creepy every one of our girls videos
increases interest in insects as pets
the commission I get more and more
requests every year I've seen that more
and more people are interested in
keeping insects rather than say reptiles
insects and other invertebrates are a
new market noise is a nice mug insects
for many people they're a major turnoff
but for our can cause a cubic they're
the most exciting creatures in the world